so let's define a random variable X as
being equal to the number of heads I'll
just write capital H for short the
number of heads from from flipping coin
from flipping a fair coin we're going to
assume it's a fair coin from flipping
coin five times five times and so like
all random variables this is taking
particular outcomes and converting them
into numbers and this random variable it
could take on the value x equals zero
one two three four or five and what I
want to do is figure out well what's the
probability that this random variable
takes on zero can be 1 can be 2 can be 3
can be 4 can be 5 and so to do that
first let's think about how many
possible outcomes are there from
flipping a fair coin five times so let's
think about this so let's write possible
outcomes possible outcomes from five
flips from five flips these aren't the
possible outcomes for the random
variable this is literally the pot the
number of possible outcomes for flipping
a coin five times for example one
possible outcome could be tails heads
tails heads tails another possible
outcome could be heads heads heads tails
tails these that is one of the equally
likely outcomes that's another one of
the equally likely outcomes how many of
these are there well for each flip you
have two equally you have two
possibilities so let's write this down
so let me let me
so the first flip the first flip there's
two possibilities times two for the
second flip times two for the third flip
actually not me not use a time notation
we might get confused with the random
variable to two possibilities for the
first flip two possibilities for the
second flip two possibilities for the
third flip two possibilities for the
fourth flip and then two possibilities
for the fifth flip or two to the fifth
equally likely possibilities from
flipping a coin five times which is of
course is equal to 32 and so this is
going to be helpful because for each of
the values that the reign
variable can take on we just have to
think about well how many of these
equally likely possibilities would
result in the random variable taking on
that value and let's let's let's just
delve into it to see what we're actually
talking about all right now I'll do it
in this light let me do it in I'll start
in blue all right so let's think about
the probability that our random variable
X is equal to 1 well actually let me
start with 0 the probability that our
random variable X is equal to 0 so that
would mean that you've got no heads out
of the 5 flips well there's only one way
one out of the 32 equally likely
possibilities that you get no heads
that's the one where you just get 5
where you get 5 tails so this is just
going to be this is going to be equal to
1 out of the 32 equally likely
possibilities now for this case you know
to kind of think in terms of kind of the
you know binomial coefficients and
combinatorics and and all of that it's
much easier to just reason through it
but just so we can think about think in
those terms and it'll be more useful as
we go into into higher values for our
random variable and it's also you know
this is all build up for the binomial
distribution so you get a sense of where
the name comes from let's write it in
those terms so this one this one this
one right over here the way one way to
think about that in combinatorics is
that you had 5 flips and you're choosing
0 of them to be heads 5 flips and you're
choosing 0 of them to be heads and let's
verify that 5 choose 0 is indeed 1 so 5
choose 0 let me write it right over here
5 choose 0 is equal to 5 factorial over
over over 5 minus 0 factorial over 5
actually over 0 factorial times 5 minus
0 factorial 5 minus 0 factorial well
this is 0 factorial is 1 by definition
and so this is going to be 5 factorial
over 5 factorial which is it going to be
equal to 1
once again I like reason
through it instead of blindly applying a
formula but I just wanted to show you
that these these two ideas are
consistent so let's keep going and I'm
going to do X equals 1 all the way up to
X equals 5 and if you are inspired and I
encourage you to be inspired I try to
fill it out the whole thing what's
probably that x equals 1 2 3 4 or 5 so
let's go to the probability that x
equals 2 or start x equals 1 so the
probability that x equals 1 is going to
be equal to well how do you get 1 head
well it could be the first one could be
head and then the rest of them are going
to be tails the second one could be head
and then the rest of them are going to
be tails I could write them all out but
you could see that there's just five
different places for to have that one
head so 5 out of the 32 equally likely
outcomes involve one head so let me
write that down so this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to 5
out of 32 equally likely outcomes which
of course is the same thing this is
going to be the same thing as saying
look I got 5 flips and I'm choosing one
of them I'm choosing one of them to be
heads so that over 32 and you could
verify that 5 factorial over 1 factorial
times 5 minus actually let me just do it
just so that you don't have to take my
word for it so 5 choose 1 is equal to 5
factorial over 1 factorial which is just
1 times 5 minus 4 sorry 5 minus 1
factorial which is equal to 5 factorial
over 4 factorial which is just going to
be equal to 5 all right we're making
good progress so now let in purple let's
think about the probability that our
random variable X is equal to 2 well
this is going to be equal to and now
actually resort to the combinatorics so
this is you have 5 flips and you're
choosing 2 of them to be heads over 32
equally likely possibilities so this is
the number of possibilities that result
in two in two heads two
of the five flips have chosen to be
heads I guess you could think of it that
way by it by the by the random gods or
whatever you want to say and that's so
this is the fraction of the 32 equally
likely possibility so there's a
probability that x equals 2 well what's
this going to be well I'll do it right
over here and actually no reason for me
to have to keep switching colors so 5
choose 2 is going to be equal to 5
factorial over over 2 factorial times 5
minus 2 factorial 5 minus 2 factorial so
this is 5 factorial over 2 factorial
times 3 factorial and this is going to
be equal to 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 I
could write x 1 but that doesn't really
do anything for us and then 2 factorial
is just going to be 2 and then the 3
factorial is 3 times 2 I could write x 1
but once again doesn't do anything for
us that cancels with that 4 divided by 2
is 2 5 times 2 is 10 so this is equal to
10 this right over here is equal to 10
30 seconds 10 30 seconds and obviously
we could simplify this fraction but I
like to leave it this way because we're
now thinking everything is in terms of
30 seconds there's a 1 30 second chance
x equals 0 5 thirty seconds chance that
x equals 1 and a 1030 seconds chance
that x equals 2 let's keep on going all
right I'll go in orange so what is the
probability that our random variable X
is equal to 3 well this is going to be 5
out of the 5 flips we're going to choose
where we're going to need to choose 3 of
them to be heads to figure out which of
the possibilities involve exactly three
heads and this is over 32 equally likely
possibilities and this is going to be
equal to so 5 choose 3 is equal to 5
factorial over 3 factorial times 5 minus
3 factorial make sure we just write down
5 minus 3 factorial which is equal to 5
factorial over 3 factorial times 2
factorial times 2 factorial well that's
exactly what we had up here
we just swap swap three and the two so
this also is going to be equal to ten so
this is also going to be equal to ten
thirty Seconds all right two more to go
and I think you're going to start seeing
a little bit of a symmetry here one five
ten ten
let's keep going let's keep going and I
haven't used white yet so maybe I'll use
white the probability the probability
that our random variable X is equal to
four well out of our five flips we want
to select four of them to be heads or
out of the five yeah before oh and we
want to see that let me you know what
we're obviously not actively selecting
one way to think about it we want to
figure out the possibilities that
involve out of the five flips four of
them are chosen to be heads or four of
them are heads and this is over 32
equally likely possibilities so 5 choose
4 is equal to 5 factorial over 4
factorial times 5 minus 4 factorial
which is equal to well that's just going
to be 5 factorial this is going to be 1
factorial right over here so it doesn't
change the value of the just we're
multiplying 1 factorial times 4
factorial so it's 5 factorial over 4
factorial which is equal to 5 so once
again this is 5/32 and you could have
reasoned through this because if you're
saying you want 5 heads that means you
have one tail and that there's only 5
different places you could put that one
tail 5 there are 5 possibilities with
one tail 5 of the 32 equally likely and
then and you could probably guess what
we're going to get for x equals 5
because having five heads means you have
0 tails and there's only going to be one
possibility out of the 32 with 0 tails
or will that have all heads let's write
that down
so the probability the probability that
a random variable X is equal to 5 so we
have all 5 heads and you could say this
this is 5 and we're choosing 5 of them
to be heads out of the 32 equally likely
possibilities well 5 choose 5 that's
going to be actually let me just write
it here since I've done it for all the
other ones 5 choose 5 is 5 factorial
Oh
over five factorial times five minus
five factorial
well this right over here is zero
factorial which is equal to one and so
this whole thing simplifies to 1 so this
is going to be one one 30 seconds and so
you see the symmetry one thirty second
one thirty seconds five thirty seconds
five thirty seconds ten thirty seconds
ten thirty seconds and that makes sense
because the probability of getting five
heads is the same as a probability of
getting zero tails and the probability
getting zero tails
should be the same as the probability of
getting zero heads so I'll leave you
there for this video in the next video
we'll kind of graphically represent this
and see we'll see the probability
distribution for this random variable